[Music]
and who the hell are you news was
submitted by love your hair Sesame oh
thank you a genealogy website helps a
family find a man who is posing as their
dead son and nephew that's cool huh what
yeah I was so [ __ ] good what do you
call those identity theft
yeah so basically it sounds like
identity theft so it was yeah so
someone's dead and then these strangers
are like cool we're going to be these
people now oh my god you know if my
family members dead go ahead I don't
have the same way
no but if they're being cool we roll
you're doing it for a bad reason what if
they had like a bad start and they were
like group and agribon had to steal and
they have on the record but it was a
good person they wanted a fresh start
but they couldn't get it um you know
book nope they want a second [ __ ] a
second chance
Oh a group blows oh really yeah I
thought it was just gonna let him yeah I
thought so too yeah I think it's like my
trunk lungs go on Google Maps and type
in Agrabah I think it's like not the
arity yeah I know I already know we have
fake city I dare you
know it's there Google Maps Agrabah you
better spell it right too or else it's
not going you're fired you're fired one
jump
I know what you guys are thinking a
little big ahead of the sword I feel
only what I care for and everything I
don't know how you know the lyrics I was
a child when I watch that [ __ ] I just
remember Gilbert Godfrey with Giotto I
[ __ ] hated him no bad oh yeah Gilbert
Gottfried
oh yeah oh yeah gonzo look you got a lot
of gigs it led me to I saw doors yeah
the sound of it ya know works back to
this story in 2 months old Nathan died
in December in 1972 and oh dude that's
going to be hard for a parent you're
still down yes I miss you that's your
baby
so John Vincent who is now 44 took
Nathan's name social security number in
1996
that's all [ __ ] up I always wondered
about that like don't they just destroy
like once once you're dying out
like all that just diminish like it
doesn't exist anyway it's hard because
this this baby didn't really have a
record like it didn't have an account it
was cream but there slide it's amazing
it's not they like the baby must have a
death certificate I guess once you
obtain a death certificate changes
everything attached to you too might be
why well with everything diesel but am i
you so very hard because it's it's
paperwork back man
and then different times so back in 1996
John stole the baby's identity after
escaping a halfway house and he doesn't
know what halfway houses it's a center
for helping former drug addicts
prisoners psychiatric patients and
others to adjust back into society and
so he escaped from their mother
Josie oh yeah yeah yeah that's different
he wasn't an admirable person that was
starving he was a former drug addict and
a criminal but he was rehabbing that
means that he did his time you know we
had though he left he went away but he
knew that if he was going to go out in
the real world that he'd be judged
harshly and he would never get a fair
start but he was we you're creating a
plot I'm missing the line I'm with
Shannon
she thinks um fit I agree I don't think
you're said I know you're fit oh that's
a I agree whatever you think I agree
Jesus he's innocent
well he live in a halfway house because
with understood house he was convicted
for indecency with a child
no you got YouTube rapist Kyle huh that
I won the ski shoe space that mom and oh
my friend hold on man I believed in you
yeah you turned your back on us rapist
repent file in diesel I need is not
molestation or pedophilia right it's
just like your improper it could also be
peeing close to a kids playground in the
seventies I don't know about that I
think it was
it's like if you urinate around a kid's
party even to the cross nursery I
thought that was recent but what if
you're fertilizing the place with your
target what if your mainlander oh I
learned something guys it's applying my
new knowledge
go to jail to the hahahaha please
pedophilia alright guys we're getting
too deep about this it's too serious
we got a hook we are she just said it
could be a meal and and I was like I
think you're making if we get back to
normal
alright okay so this person is stealing
identities yes John Vincent is stealing
Nathan's identities all right that would
be a little boy during that two name
John Vincent he wants another name let's
make this a little light-hearted come on
so he took Nathan's identity of back in
96 and he was actually able to have a
whole new life and he changed his way
around
he wasn't molesting children he became a
schoolteacher and he helped out so many
kids get into college in poor
neighborhoods well I mean so he was able
to get a job or driver's life no taco
and he fed the hungry on his spare time
and she was able to get married and
divorce under the name course we got
divorced rape is perfect but to my
knowledge he did live a quiet life
raping people was menacing I didn't
commit any crime other than pop other
than stealing a Social Security number
so you just wanted a second chance he
[ __ ] everyone their second chance yeah
he pees close to the playground not cool
could be fertilizing nothing cool John
Vincent but at the same time the
gardener just trying to fertilize the
place right and so the way that he was
discovered was Nathan's aunt just
happened to be on ancestry.com which is
a genealogy site and she was just
looking at it and she saw oh this is an
ad type in my name is there nobody I
don't know nobody nobody's connected to
me I did agree it only works for white
people
yeah so why people in America because
they have like the whole read read about
a fast money they lie they go it's sign
up it's free and then you got a sign up
and then to find out more page [ __ ]
more money they always do that [ __ ] yeah
see I hate that what do you find out
though I didn't pay nothing money I'm
gonna do it just a testator out
well we already did it with the 23andme
a free Masuda nope I don't know who I'm
related to what if I'm related to some
person in the video but you don't have
your relations here to go my dad told me
he
the cousin in the middle of the Midwest
like Ohio or something there's a Chinese
restaurant out there how long have you
been here though like 50 years not sure
I want to meet him cuz I know why people
don't go back to my all your your dad
your great-great-great in front with a
slave owner that had this and they came
on the Mayflower yeah and you you know
he got charged with rape too and then
after that he got flat mama oh my god
the race one is good no one's well
devastating I don't want to find that
[ __ ] out of them Nathan's on
she looked up on ancestry.com and she
saw Nathan's name on that list and it
had a green wreath next to his name
meaning that he was alive and so she was
just like god this is strange and so
that mean that Nathan's like registered
himself on ancestry.com - I think it
just goes off of public records
it's like Yelp they're gonna put you in
the matter what yeah I think they're
like try to contact them if you don't
want to be in that that makes sense was
it be [ __ ] up like who would just sign
up to that not enough people I mean uh
public records would be right because
aunt was like doing her research and she
she was like what is going on and so
like her search ended up her being in
like the public records and then at that
point she's like okay I need to tell
Nathan's mom about this and so she told
the mom and Nathan's mom actually filed
an identity theft complaint with the
social security admin and at that point
that's when the SSA dozen security admin
were investigating and like the mom was
like actually telling us again you know
I recall like back in 96 where like I
got this random phone call asking me
stuff about Nathan like which is social
security number and stuff like that and
she said it and she thought it was weird
and so when she asked like who this
person was like that person already hung
up come on ladies concentrate ember at
two months old do you do you have a
remember that your board really antenna
you'll get to like 18 years old
everything is really [ __ ] up in Canada
yeah well you doesn't have any form of
identification worth to the kid I don't
know how do you get it when I I just
knew I always had one since I was little
and and memorize it everyone was a
criminal in America so they have to well
I found out how the process works when
Isaac was born and so I guess it's a
hospital like they give you a form for
you to sign and then so you sign it in
the side
that gets turned into the birth
certificate and then once you have your
birth certificate you have to call
Social Security office to let them know
that case is new human here and then
like register them and then you get that
Social Security card if I found out that
someone was pretending to be my son then
I just hit them up and be like guess
you're my son now so I'm gonna talk [ __ ]
to you because that's what father's do
and every day you just have to take it
and you have to act like my son because
if you want to continue being this
identity you got to play the part man
I'm just going to call checking up on
what are you doing I'm gonna know the
[ __ ] out of them yeah you know what you
said like together yeah I hear a bunch
of [ __ ] gay I want to lecture him I
want to give him advice oh my god all
the years that I didn't get to do it
yeah but each other use a condom take
off my pants
oh I feel like yeah I'm like 70 and he's
like 40 so after the mom's out figured
out like that the phone call was strange
he immediately went over to the police
and I saw the report but the police was
like well there's not really much that
we can do we can't doing that thing we
just drop it she's like [ __ ] it I mean
there's nothing else that she could have
desired 986 yeah whoo pop was around no
no he just died he just died they're too
busy with the west coast East Coast
rivalry the cops were just can't do
anything yeah so now John is charged
with Social Security fraud which is up
to five years in prison and aggravated
identity theft which is an additional
two years betadine oh wow
looks like you guys might be somebody so
that's messed up man you can't be
pretending to be a baby
probably like by calling the mom and
asking a few questions I do be like yo
you know what don't put him to jail but
you owe me some [ __ ] money at least
there's a light inside your whole life
benefit off of my child's death you're
gonna pay me some [ __ ] money people
why let's just make up a fake identity
and stuff instead of like stealing
somebody else's but he needs a job hope
you guys enjoyed that episode if you
guys have any juicy little guts of
details and you guys want to submit it
well guess what you can cruise on over
to the description box below click on
the link submit the story and hopefully
we will pick it and talk about it for
more videos click right over here
[Music]